conditional probabilities are like
ordinary probabilities except that they
apply to a new situation where some
additional information is available for
this reason any concept relevant to
probability models has a counterpart
that applies to conditional probability
models in this period we can define a
notion of conditional independence which
is nothing but the notion of
independence applied to a conditional
model let us be more specific
suppose that we have a probability model
and two events a and B we are then told
that event C occurred and we construct
the conditional model conditional
independence is defined as ordinary
independence but with respect to the
conditional probabilities to be more
precise
remember that independence is defined in
terms of this relation that the
probability of two events happening is
the product of the probabilities that
one of them is happening times the
probability that the other one is
happening this is the definition of
Independence in the original
unconditional model now in the
conditional model we just use the same
relation but with conditional
probabilities instead of ordinary
probabilities so this is the definition
of conditional independence we may now
ask is there a relation between
independence and conditional
independence does one imply the other
let us look at an example suppose that
we have two events and these two events
are independent we then condition on
another event C and suppose that the
picture is like the one shown here are a
and B conditionally independent well in
the new universe who RC has happened
events a and B
have no intersection as we discussed
earlier this means that event a and B
are extremely dependent we then see if a
occurs this tells us that B did not
occur the conclusion from this example
is that independence does not imply
conditional independence so in this
particular example we saw that the
answer here is no given C a and B are
not independent